ahora vamos a pensar quienes se ven más
afectados por los impuestos en diversas
situaciones en este vídeo nos enfocamos
en el mercado el insulina para los
diabéticos de insulina es esencial para
controlar sus niveles de azúcar como
necesitan insulina para sobrevivir para
ellos tiene un beneficio marginal
prácticamente infinito ellos están
dispuestos a comprarla sin importar el
precio para ellos es cuestión de vida o
muerte por ejemplo si el precio de la
insulina fuese de un peso por unidad y
los doctores en un pueblo dicen que en
conjunto los diabéticos necesitan 3000
unidades por año
la demanda será de 3 mil unidades por
año si el precio fuese de 80 pesos por
unidad aún así la demanda sería de 3 mil
unidades por año dentro de límites
razonables
el precio no afecta a la cantidad de
demanda así que si nos quedamos en un
rango razonable de precios la curva de
demanda para el insulina es una línea
vertical en la vida real el precio
podría llegar a ser impagable para
algunos diabéticos así que se perdería
un poco de demanda y la curva ya no
sería completamente vertical pero vamos
a pensar como siempre que estamos en una
situación ideal así que para nuestro
rango de precios esta línea vertical es
nuestra curva
demanda y quizás recuerden que cuando
hablamos de la elasticidad en el mercado
que esto se llama demanda perfectamente
inelástica una buena analogía es pensar
en un tabique no importa cuánta fuerza
le apliques dentro de los límites de la
fuerza humana
no puedes deformar un tabique a
diferencia de una liga que es muy
elástica aquí no importa cuánto alteres
el precio no puedes deformar la curva de
demanda también podríamos ser formales y
recordar la definición de elasticidad
definimos elasticidad como el porcentaje
de cambio en la cantidad dividido entre
el porcentaje de cambio en el precio y
en este caso no importa cuánto cambiemos
el precio dentro del rango que abarca
toda esta gráfica la demanda va a seguir
siendo de tres mil unidades de insulina
por año no hay de otra porque eso es lo
que necesitan los diabéticos muy bien
ahora voy a dibujar una curva de oferta
por acá nuestra curva de oferta se verá
algo así
si no tienes impuestos ni regulación en
este mercado
entonces basado en el modo que dibuje la
curva de oferta el precio de equilibrio
parece rondar los 75 pesos por unidad de
insulina
este precio es extremadamente barato en
realidad el precio sería de más de 750
pesos por frasco de 10 mililitros
pero esto no importa puesto que el
modelo también funciona si multiplicamos
todos los precios por 10 bueno es
interesante pensar en cuál es el
superávit del consumidor y del productor
en estas situaciones con demanda
perfectamente inelástica el superávit
del productor es cuánto dinero gana
sobre su costo de oportunidad o el costo
marginal por producir en unidades
adicionales como hemos visto ya varias
veces está área sombreada aquí es el
superávit del productor justo estaría
entre el precio de venta y el costo de
oportunidad dado por nuestra curva de
oferta esto es el superávit del
productor
el superávit del consumidor es más
interesante por definición un superávit
del consumidor es cuánto beneficio
marginal recibe la gente más allá del
precio que pagan usualmente hemos dicho
que es el área entre la curva de demanda
y la línea de precio pero ahora resulta
que esta área es infinita podemos pensar
que esto es porque los diabéticos
reciben un beneficio marginal casi
infinito tras pagar la insulina puesto
que les permite llevar una vida sana
vaya les permite seguir con vida así que
para ellos es algo esencialmente
invaluable no estamos diciendo que sea
algo genial para ellos simplemente que
es algo muy importante para su condición
como mencionábamos en el mundo real la
la demanda si se reduce un poquito con
el precio
digamos que algunos diabéticos
disminuyan su dosis y controlarían más
sus dietas o algo así es decir en el
mundo real la demanda no sería
absolutamente inelástica así que siendo
realistas la curva de demanda a la
insulina si tiene una ligera desviación
de la vertical así que tendríamos esta
pequeña inclinación y uno podría
imaginarse que si siguiera esta curva
hacia arriba en un punto muy muy lejano
la demanda sería nula
y entonces en cerraríamos un área finita
digamos que si el precio fuera de 2
millones entonces la demanda se reduce
dramáticamente y entonces ahora si el
área es finita pero sigue siendo una
cantidad grandísima de beneficio para el
consumidor sale tras esta breve
discusión veamos qué pasaría si algún
político decidiera ponerle un impuesto a
la insulina esto obviamente es una muy
mala idea y algo que no recomendaría no
obstante veamos a quién afectaría este
impuesto creo que ustedes ya pueden
adivinarlo pero vamos a estudiarlo con
calma y verlo desde nuestro modelo con
estas curvas de oferta y una demanda
completamente inelástica supongamos que
se pone un impuesto de 10 pesos por
unidad
estoy considerando una cantidad fija en
vez de un porcentaje para que el precio
percibido por los consumidores sea un
incremento constante sobre el costo
marginal si observamos la curva de
oferta si queremos que los productores
produzcan 3.000 unidades tienen un costo
marginal de 75 pesos es más para que
produzcan la primera unidad necesitan
ganar como 60 pesos así que para
considerar el impuesto podemos dibujar
una nueva curva como ya lo hemos hecho
antes al principio los productores
necesitan
60 pesos pero si agregamos el impuesto
subimos a 70 para mil unidades necesitan
recibir como 65 y al agregar el impuesto
subimos por acá para 3000 unidades el
costo desde alrededor de 75 pesos y le
sumamos los 10 pesos de impuestos nos da
85 pesos así vamos obteniendo esta nueva
curva de oferta
podemos pensarla como el precio desde el
punto de vista del consumidor o como la
curva de oferta más el impuesto la
llamaría hacia curva de oferta más
impuestos y déjenme anotarlo por aquí
curva de oferta más impuestos bueno y
como siempre queremos saber dónde
intersec a esta curva a nuestra curva de
demanda perfectamente inelástica y como
decíamos no importa cuál sea el precio
la gente siempre necesita adquirir 3.000
unidades de insulina por año así que las
curvas se cortarán justo aquí en esta
cantidad pero ahora hay un nuevo precio
equilibrio ahora el precio 10 pesos más
que antes
así que si antes era de 75 pesos ahora
será de 85 pesos
la distancia entre las dos curvas
siempre es de 10 pesos
ok y pensemos ahora acerca de la
ganancia total que el gobierno tiene de
esta situación la ganancia total para
ellos será de 10 pesos por cada unidad
así que tenemos que es 10 x 3000
la ganancia para el gobierno será de 30
mil pesos por año
bueno y de donde salía esta ganancia
pues estaría justo aquí esta es la
ganancia por el impuesto toda esta área
morada y los productores siguen teniendo
exactamente el mismo superávit así que
toda la ganancia del gobierno por el
impuesto salió directamente del
superávit del consumidor también resulta
muy interesante notar que debido a que
teníamos una demanda perfectamente
inelástica que era bastante insensible
al aumento del precio no bajaron las
unidades consumidas en este caso no
tuvimos una pérdida irrecuperable de
eficiencia gracias a la demanda
perfectamente inelástica lo que sucedió
fue que tuvimos una transferencia
directa desde el superávit del
consumidor de los diabéticos al gobierno
pero no hubo ninguna pérdida de
beneficio o superávit porque no hubo
movimiento en el mercado no se perdió
ningún área entre la curva de demanda y
la curva de oferta o dicho de otro modo
la cantidad vendida no bajó por culpa
del alza de los precios causada por el
impuesto del gobierno